Bitte schön.
Okay, bekannte ich da.
Ja, schönen guten Abend.
Aktaj ist mein Name.
Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenz,
ah, stetig und würde gerne das Aufnahmegespräch mit Ihnen führen.
Bevor wir genau über Ihre Beschwerden sprechen,
bräuchte ich ein paar persönliche Daten.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Ralph Kühler.
Könntest du bitte Ihre Name buchstabieren?
Der Vorname ist Ralph, R, A, L, F.
Ja.
Und der Familienname ist Kühler, K, U, umlaut, H, L, E, R.
Okay. Herr Kühler.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Kühler?
Noch bin ich 58.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,78 m.
Und wissen Sie zurzeit, wie viel Sie wiegen?
Ich wiege immer so um die 87 kg rum.
87 kg. Okay.
Wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt?
Das ist Dr. Schröter.
Schröter.
Und haben Sie Angehörige, die wir benachrichtigen sollten?
Ja, also, ich bin ein
Frau, die ich mit meiner Frau im Augenblick getrennt habe.
Und jetzt hat mich ein Kollege hierher gebracht.
Weil es bei der Arbeit mit den Problemen losgegangen ist.
Aber dann müssten Sie vielleicht, wenn es irgendeine Probleme gibt,
sich mit meiner Frau in Verbindung setzen, ja.
Okay, Frau Kühler, können wir benachrichtigen.
Okay.
Und was führt Sie zu uns, Herr Kühler?
Was für Beschwerden haben Sie?
Ja, wissen Sie, ich habe solche schrecklichen Schmerzen
und solche enge Gefühle gehabt, die mein, jetzt ist es ein bisschen besser.
Aber ich hatte so ganz brennende und dumfe Schmerzen hier oben,
hier oben so auf der Brust.
Und das hat ausgestrahlt bis in den Unterkiefer.
Und das tat alles weh.
Und ich konnte überhaupt nicht mehr weiterlaufen.
Ich habe eine ganz schnelle Treppe hochgelaufen.
Ich hatte es ganz eilig.
Und mit allem war ich fing es an.
Ich konnte nicht mehr weitergehen.
Und ja, dann haben meine Kollegen, haben mich aufgefunden
und sind dann mit mir gleich hierhergekommen.
Ja, okay.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Druckengefühle auf der Brust?
Ja, das hat, ich weiß gar nicht, wie lange das jetzt her ist,
aber das hat vor ganz kurzem angefangen.
Und jetzt ist es zum Glück ein klein bisschen besser,
weil ich habe, mir war so schlecht.
Ich habe mich nicht übergeben, aber ich hatte das Gefühl,
ich müsste mich sofort übergeben.
Und ich habe für den Moment überhaupt gar keine Luft bekommen.
Ich habe geschwitzt mit einmal.
Es war ganz beängstigend.
Jetzt ist es aber, glaube ich, ein bisschen besser.
Momentan ein bisschen besser.
Und momentan, wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf eine Skala von 1 bis 10?
Kann das nicht gut einschätzen.
Vielleicht bei 7 oder die waren sicherlich bei 8 oder so.
Jetzt sind sie vielleicht bei 6 oder 7, ja.
Okay.
Ich denke, wir müssen jetzt Ihre Lebensparameter messen.
Also Sauerstoff und ein EKG machen wir.
Und danach können wir weitergehen mit unserem Aufnahmegespräch.
Und jetzt können wir weitergehen.
Ja, wir haben schon EKG durchgeführt.
Sie haben diese Beschwerden seit heute Morgen, oder hatten Sie früher?
Nein, nein, nein.
Das hat erst jetzt heute Abend angefangen.
Ich hatte einen wichtigen Termin in meinem Büro und habe mich ein bisschen verspätet
und bin dann ganz schnell losgelaufen.
Oh ja, dann ist es halt passiert.
Seit heute Abend haben Sie diese Beschwerden.
Und früher, hatten Sie ähnliche Beschwerden?
Ja, also ich habe immer mal so ein bisschen Probleme gehabt,
wenn ich mich sehr belastet habe.
Aber früher bin ich doch völlig problemlos 4 Etagen hochgelaufen.
War nie ein Thema.
Und jetzt ist es so, wenn ich gegenwind habe beim Fahrrad fahren
oder wenn ich schnell irgendwo hinlaufe
oder wenn ich eine schwere Tasche zu tragen habe.
Oh, dann merke ich schon, dass es nicht mehr so gut geht.
Aber diese Schmerz, Sie haben beim Belastung,
könnte Sie genau beschreiben, was für Beschwerden früher hatten Sie beim Belastung?
Ja, also ich habe gemerkt, dass ich mich nicht so gut belasten kann,
dass ich also dann stehen bleiben muss oder nicht gut Luft bekomme.
Und manchmal hatte ich auch so ein bisschen das Problem,
dass ich dachte so, boah, tut mir jetzt das Herz weh oder nicht.
Aber so wie jetzt, das war es nie.
Okay.
Sie haben auch Atemnot, momentan Problem?
Ja, jetzt ist es besser, aber ich hatte vorhin ganz schlimme Atemnot.
Okay.
Und leiden Sie unter Herzrasen, Herzklopfen?
Ja, ich habe das Gefühl, dass mein Herz wirklich ganz doll rast.
Und die Schmerzen strahlen ins Unterkiefer?
Die haben ausgestrahlt, ja.
Das war so, als ob man hier so Zahnschmerzen hat, ja.
Streitenschmerzen andere Körperregionen aus oder nur Unterkiefer?
Nein, da habe ich das eigentlich nur jetzt bemerkt, ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden? Möchten Sie das so hinzufügen?
Aktuell haben Sie...
Ja, aber das war dramatisch genug, also...
Okay.
Haben Sie Schweißausbrüche?
Ja, sagt ich ja. Vorhin habe ich geschwitzt, ja.
Okay.
Früher, wie lange können Sie hofftreppen oder wie viel treppen können Sie ohne Beschwerden treppen?
Ich konnte vier Etagen hochgehen, ja. Das hat überhaupt nichts gemacht.
Aber so jetzt in den letzten Monaten war es nicht so gut.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihr normalerweise Appetit?
Eigentlich kann ich gut essen, ja. Ich muss ein bisschen aufpassen.
Ich habe diesen Altersdiabetes, hat man vor ein paar Jahren mal festgestellt.
Und dann nehme ich mich halt mit Formin.
Und insofern esse ich also jetzt nicht so besonders viel.
Aber eigentlich bin ich damit so ganz gut, komme ich ganz gut klar.
Seit wann haben Sie gesagt, ein paar Jahre, wer wird es...
Ja, also seit fünf Jahren wird es mit Formin behandelt.
Seit fünf Jahren.
Okay. Haben Sie in letzter Zeit Gewicht ab oder zu genommen?
Nein, ich wüsste euch, ich muss mal eben mein Licht anmachen.
Mein Lämpchen ist ausgegangen.
So, dann wieder da.
Gewicht ist eigentlich immer stabil.
Stabil? Okay.
Und haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang?
Oder Wasser lassen, nächtliche häufige Wasser lassen?
Ja, also nachts muss ich schon ein paar Mal raus.
Ja, ich habe so ein bisschen Poster-Tag-Probleme.
Und da muss ich dann mal nachts aufstehen.
Und manchmal habe ich auch nachts das Problem, dass ich aufwache,
weil ich nicht so gut Luft bekomme.
Und wie viel Kissen brauchen Sie?
Normalerweise habe ich einen Kissen.
Aber ich wachte dann halt manchmal auf.
Aber jetzt sollte ich dann mal zusätzlich jetzt Kissen in Betrieb nehmen, ja.
Haben Sie geschwollen Bein bemerkt?
Das ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Und wie ist Ihr Stuhlgang? Normalerweise?
Ja, würde ich sagen, das ist ganz normal, ja.
Haben Sie Allergien gegen etwas?
Ja, also ich darf tatsächlich kein Novalgin nehmen.
Da kriege ich erstmal Ausschlag und da habe ich auch schon mal so richtig Luftnot bekommen.
Und dann hat man auch mal festgestellt, dass ich eine Latex Allergie habe.
Da kriege ich also auch so einen ganz schlimmen Ausschlag davon.
Hatt ich immer so Gummihandschuhe mit Latex und ja, das war wirklich gut.
Und haben Sie Unterreglichkeiten?
Ich habe z.B. Milch oder Laktos.
Ach so, Sie meinen so Lebensmittelgeschichten?
Ich kann alles essen, was mir schmeckt, ja.
Normalerweise treiben Sie Sport, regelmäßig Sport?
Ja, ich habe eine ganze Weile regelmäßig Sport gemacht.
Als das so anfing mit dem Diabetes, da hat man ja so gesagt, ja.
Wenn Sie sich viel bewegen, das ist besser.
Aber in letzter Zeit bin ich nicht so viel dazu gekommen.
Ja, eben, dass ich viel zu tun, viel bei der Arbeit und die Trennung von meiner Frau.
Und ja, das ist alles nicht so einfach.
Okay, rachen Sie, Herr Kühler?
Ja, ich rauch fast gar nicht mehr.
Ich habe viele Jahre so ungefähr ein Päckchen am Tag geraucht,
aber jetzt rauch ich ein, ihr hält so ein Päckchen drei, vier Tage.
Also jeden Tag ein Viertelschachtel rachen Sie momentan?
Ja, so ungefähr, ja, mal ein bisschen mehr.
Also fünf bis zehn Zigaretten am Tag sind es noch.
Und früher...
früher habe ich also ein Päckchen sicherlich am Tag geraucht, ja.
Und seit wann rauchen Sie?
Och, wann habe ich angefangen, ja, so, als ich in den Beruf eingestiegen bin,
so Anfang 20, ja.
Seit 20 Jahren, oder?
Ja, ein bisschen mehr.
Ich bin ja jetzt schon fast 60, also, sagen wir seit 25 Jahren.
25 Jahre.
Okay, trinken Sie Alkohol, Herr Kühler?
Ja, also Glas Wein trinke ich schon gelegentlich, ja,
oder ja, doch, also auch recht häufig,
vielleicht so zwei, drei Mal in der Woche.
Aber wirklich nur ein Glas, zum Essen oder abends zum Feierabend.
Hatten Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Mit Drogen, nee, da habe ich nie etwas davon gehabt.
Okay.
Und Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie unter Diabetes, Blutzucker leiden.
Haben Sie andere chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, das, was halt jeder eigentlich hat.
Ich habe ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck und ich habe ein bisschen hohe Cholesterinwerte.
Und gegen Bluthochdruck, was nehmen Sie ein?
Ja, ich nehme da Enelapril und dann nehme ich so einen Betablokon.
Enelapril, wissen Sie die Dosierung von Enelapril und Betablokon?
Ich werde nur, dass ich da morgens eine nehme, also sowohl als auch,
also von dem Enelapril nehme ich morgens eine und es ist ein Betablokon auch eine.
Morgens.
Okay.
Und gegen Hypercholesterinwerte, also hohe Blutdruck,
nehmen Sie etwas.
Dann nehme ich eigentlich nichts ein.
Und hatten Sie früher andere Krankheiten?
Vor acht Jahren hatte ich meinen Autounfall.
Da hatte ich irgendwie so einen Verdacht,
dass ich am Kopf etwas abbekommen habe.
Und weil der Erweck ausgelöst hat.
Und da bin ich mal eine Nacht stationär in der Klinik gewesen,
aber da war eigentlich nichts.
Okay.
Und Herr Kühler, wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Nein, ich bin noch nie operiert worden.
Okay.
Und leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Sind Sie gesund?
Also meine Mutter, die lebt noch,
die hat natürlich auch so ein Alterszucker
und natürlich hat sie auch ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck.
Und mein Vater, der hatte eine Herzkrankheit im hohen Alter,
der ist aber auch 83 geworden.
Ihr Vater ist momentan 83 Jahre alt?
Nein, der ist verstorben mit 83.
Im Folgliche eine Herzkrankheit?
Ja, der hatte Herzprobleme und hatte hohen Blutdruck
und ist dann halt im hohen Alter verstorben.
Okay.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, ich war ein Einzelkind.
Okay.
Und Sie sind verheiratet, aber Sie haben schon gesagt,
Sie haben ein Problem?
Ja, also wir sind jetzt gerade im Trennungsjahr,
und werden uns dann entsprechend trennen.
Und die Scheidung läuft dann an nach dem Trennungsjahr.
Und wahrscheinlich das macht auch Emotionalbelastung bei Ihnen?
Natürlich ist das mit Stress verbunden, klar.
Und wissen Sie, ich bin selbstständig,
da hat man auch immer ziemlich viel betrieben
und das verantwortlich für sich selber.
Was mache Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Innenarchitekt.
Ja, Architekt.
Okay.
Und bei Arbeit haben Sie auch,
vielleicht wahrscheinlich,
Ja, durch die Verantwortung, die man hat für sein Betrieb,
da geht es schon auch um Termine.
Und ja, da muss alles funktionieren.
Und was für mich, die Steuer sitzt einem im Lacken
und man muss gucken, dass das Geld reinkommt.
Also ja, da hat man schon Stress.
Okay, das verstehe ich.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, wir haben drei Kinder,
die leben bei meiner Frau.
Okay, sind Sie gesund, Ihre Kinder?
Die Kinder sind gesund, ja, ja, ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie Impfpass dabei
oder wissen Sie, ob Sie vollständig geimpft,
gegen zum Beispiel Corona?
Weil die Corona-Impfungen, da habe ich,
drei oder vier, habe ich, ja.
Und dann natürlich früher,
was ich so die Kinder gegen krippelt,
bin ich auch geimpft dieses Jahr.
Und dann habe ich mich auch impfen lassen
gegen, hier gegen diese Zeckengeschichte.
Ja, also diese Frühsommer,
Entsefalitis.
Okay.
Und waren Sie in letzter Zeit in Ausland?
Ausland war ich nicht, nein.
Okay.
Herr Kühler, möchten Sie das so hinzufügen
oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, also wie geht es jetzt weiter
und wie kam das mit diesen heftigen Schwerzen?
Das war ja wirklich sehr beängstigend.
Ja, ich verstehe Ihre Sorge.
Aber bevor wir eine körperliche Untersuchung machen,
können wir leider nicht genau sagen,
aber Ihre Beschwerden sprechen für eine Herzkrankheit.
Und wir haben schon ein EKG durchgeführt
und wir brauchen ein paar Laboruntersuchungen.
Nach der Ergebnisse können wir genau über Ihre Krankheit sprechen.
Zunächst spreche ich mit Oberarzt über Ihre Beschwerden.
Muss ich denn jetzt im Krankenhaus bleiben?
Ja, momentan, ja.
Sie müssen momentan im Krankenhaus bleiben,
aber nach der Ergebnisse Laboruntersuchungen
können wir darüber genau mit Ihnen sprechen.
Okay.
Vielen Dank.
Neun, zehn Minuten.
Zeit ist gut.
Haben Kollegen noch andere Fragen?
Ich habe eine Frage, Herr Kühler.
Sie haben gesagt, die Schmerzen treten bei Belastung auf.
Und wenn die Schmerzen kommen,
wie lange dauern die Schmerzen ab?
Über 15 Minuten oder unter 15 Minuten?
Also, die letzten Male waren das immer nur ganz kurze Geschichten.
Jetzt ist mir das furchtbar lang vorgekommen.
Ja, also das war jetzt deutlich länger.
Ich könnte es aber nicht sagen, wie lange das tatsächlich war.
Aber mir ist es vorgekommen, wie ewig.
Okay.
Und die Schmerzen nach der Belastung in Ruhe,
spontan weggehen.
Sie sind weniger geworden, sie sind nicht ganz weg.
Okay, okay, danke schön.
Ich denke, er geht weg.
Und keine Frage.
Sind Sie auch ohnmächtig geworden?
Oder habe ich das falsch verstanden?
Ich glaube nicht.
Also, nein, ich war die ganze Zeit dabei.
Haben die Kollegen, die mich hergebracht haben,
die haben nicht gesagt, dass ich ohnmächtig geworden bin.
Also, ich meine, ich habe das alles mitbekommen.
Dr. Günlis, haben Sie noch Fragen?
Ja, als Besuch.
Haben Sie,
dass Sie nicht beschwerden,
aber haben Sie nicht gesagt, dass ich nicht zuerst gegangen bin.
Ich hatte keine Zeit und das kam mir auch nicht so wichtig vor.
Und ich habe Bluthochdruck und Diabetes mellitus.
Gut, sind gut eingestellt.
Ja, da gehe ich ja immer zu meinem Hausarzt eigentlich hin
und der macht dann seine Messung
und verschreibt mir die Medikamente
und dann ist es eigentlich gut.
Ich habe alle Fragen gestellt.
Ich denke auch, war ziemlich komplett, ja.
Können wir als Herzkischee anfangen, Seldar?
Ja, sehr gerne.
Gut.
Ich grüße Sie, Frau Oberarztin.
Ich würde gerne einen neuen Patient vorstellen.
Es handelt sich um Herr Ralf Kühler.
Er ist 58 Jahre alt,
mit reduziertem Allgemeinzustand
und bei übergewichtem Ernährungszustand.
Er stellte sich heute bei uns vor
mit seit heute Abend bestehenden
brennenden,
dumpfartige Brustschmerzen,
die ins Unterkiefer ausstrahlt.
In den Unterkiefer?
Ja, in den Unterkiefer ausstrahlt.
Die Schmerzintensität lag
bei 7, 8 von 10 auf der Skala.
Darüber hinaus klagte der Patient
über Düstne,
Übelkeit und Schwitzen.
Früher, diese Schmerzen
sind erst mal, zum ersten Mal aufgetreten.
Früher hat der Patient beim Bewegung
bispner.
Er kann nach 4 Etagen
ein Atemnot bekommen
und muss stehen bleiben.
Momentan leidet er auch unter Herz.
Die Frage nach Fieber,
Appatitlosigkeit, Gewicht, Veränderung
wurden verneint.
Sturrgang sei normal.
Aber sie leider unter
nicht mehr aufgetreten.
Das kann auch mit Herzinstifizienz
tun.
Beim Schlafen
leider der Patient unter
Düstne.
Sie hat die Schmerz
unter den Atemnot.
Er ist allergisch.
Die allergie äußert sich
mit Hautausschlag.
Manchmal bestehen
Düstne.
Der Patient hat
Schlafschnur.
allergie gegen Latex,
die mit
Ausschlag äußert.
Er ist
Raucher seit 35 Jahren.
Früher hat er eine Schachtel am Tag geraucht.
Aber seit
einige Jahren, das habe ich
drei Jahre oder nicht.
Momentan weniger.
Er trinkt Alkohol,
ein Glas Wein, gelegentlich
zwei oder drei Mal in der Woche.
Die Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Vor Erkrankung geschichten,
der Patient hatte
Diabetes-Melodie.
Er hat
Arterial-Hypertony.
Er
hat
Änalapril, morgens.
Und Betabloka, morgens.
Der Patient hat
auch Diabetes-Melodie.
Er hat
Arterial-Hypertony.
Er hat auch Hypercholesternämie.
Aber dagegen nimmt er
keine Medikamente.
Vor acht Jahren hat der Patient
einen Autounfall gehabt.
Und infolglich
hat er Gehirnerstörung.
Er muss ein Nacht stationär bleiben.
Er muss stationär bleiben.
Und bei ihnen
kein OP
gemacht wurden.
Bei ihm wurden keine Operationen durchgeführt.
durchgeführt.
An Familien an Amnese
der Vater
ist mit alter
83 sich
infolgt ich Herzkrankheit und Arterialhypertrophy, Hypertonie gestorben und seine Mutter lebt noch und hat Diabetes mellitus, Typ 2 und Arterialehypertonie.
Er ist ein Einzelkind, er ist verheiratet aber momentan Trennung, ja oder?
Im Trennungstherr?
Ja, er ist im Trennungstherr und diese Situation macht Stress.
Belastet ihn, ja klar, kann man verstehen.
Ja und er hat drei Kinder, die leben mit seiner Frau.
Ja und er ist Architekt von Beruf, er ist selbstständig, arbeitet selbstständig und sein Beruf hat auch Emotionalbelastung oder der Ursache Emotionalbelastung.
Er ist vollständig geimpft gegen Corona, Grippe und Frühsommer, Miola Encephalitis und Kinderkrankheiten waren schon geimpft und die Reise, Anamnese ist unauffällig.
Aufgrund der anamnestischen Angaben ergab der Verdacht auf eine KHK, Corona Herzkrankheit, die Entgegefühle auf der Brust, die plösterlich aufgetreten, stark und dumpf brennende Schmerzen mit Dispensieren,
mit Dispene und Schwitzen und früheren Belastung abhängig beschwerden, diese Beschwerden sprechen für eine Herzkrankheit.
Was könnte es differenzial diagnostisch sein?
Differenzial diagnostisch kommt gastroösepögel refluxkrankheit, gastritis, aber weil die beschwerden Bewegung abhängig, diese Beschwerden oder diese differenzial diagnostisch,
ist nichts so wahrscheinlich oder möglich.
Ich hätte noch einen Wunsch für eine differenzial Diagnose.
Ja, lungoenambulit vielleicht.
Ja, genau. Und natürlich, wenn wir die Angina pectorus weiter denken.
Neocard infarct.
Ja, genau.
Ja, gut, was machen Sie diagnostisch mit den Patienten?
Erst mal?
Oder was haben Sie auch schon gemacht?
Ja, EKG ist erst hier als diagnostisch Massnahmen und dann Blutabnahme.
Für welche Werte?
Troponin Tee ist wichtig und Herzentsüme sind wichtig.
CKMB.
Was ist CKMB?
Creatininkinas.
Okay.
Wenn ich mich nicht falsch erinnere.
Ja, aber Herz erinnert.
Weil Sie auch die lungoenambulit denken als Differenzialdiagnose?
Ja, Diedema ist wichtig.
Und unter dem Aspekt, dass er Zucker hat?
Zucker, ja, Blutglucos.
Ich wollte mal sicherlich mitbestimmen.
Ja, und ja, was machen Sie sonst bei der Körperlin-Untersuchung?
Körperliche Untersuchung, ja, auf jeden Fall Oskultation.
Ich auskultiere, ja, Herz-Rhythmus-Störungen.
Kann man mit Oskultation feststellen.
Und bei einem Körperlichen Untersuchung.
Sie haben mal nach Oedem gefragt?
Ja, Bein-Oedeme für Herz-Insuffizienz.
Also untersuchen Sie die Beine auf Oedem vorhanden sein.
Und ja, was könnte, was könnte, also Sauerstoff-Setzigung haben Sie ja praktisch im Rahmen der EKG-Untersuchung,
dieser Vitalparameter-Untersuchung mitgemacht.
Sonst wäre vielleicht noch zielführend, was für eine Untersuchung oder Betrachtung.
Wenn Sie an Sauerstoff-Mangel denken.
Ja, für Lungenembolli vielleicht Röntgen-Corrax.
Nee, ich bin noch bei der Körperlichen Untersuchung, bei dieser Entaukenscheinnahme.
Okay, Sianolitis, Blaue Veränderungen.
Veränderungen, insbesondere der Lippen und Blässe.
Gut, und jetzt wollen Sie noch die Lungenröntgen?
Wir liegen in der Lungenembolli und was wollen Sie noch machen?
EKG haben wir schon gemacht.
EKG haben wir gemacht ja, und das war jetzt nicht mehr dramatisch, oder war vielleicht mit...
Wahrscheinlich war es ja mit leichten Veränderungen, ne?
Wahrscheinlich Angina Pectoris sein.
Wenn EKG normal oder unauffällig ist, können wir lang 24 Stunden EKG machen.
Langzeit EKG können wir machen, oder Ergo EKG können wir auch belasten.
Und die Gebirnfeins-Ekokardiografie machen?
Ja, also ein Herzultraschall, meinen Sie?
Herzultraschall, ja.
Ja, ja, genau.
Gut, ja, also dann starten Sie den Untersuchung, ich bin gespannt,
die Laborwerte, was da rauskommt, was den Troponin-Test macht,
und halten Sie mich auf den Laufenden über den Herrn Kühler
und dann schauen wir nachher nochmal zusammen nach ihm.
Der bleibt jetzt hier erstmal statt, so ein Lärm zu überwachen, ne?
Genau.
Okay, gut. Ja, sehr schön.
Gut, möcht ihr noch jemand etwas dazu sagen?
Wir müssen diese Fall, eine Verdachtdiagnose,
erstmal Akutes Corners, ein Rom nennen.
Differential Diagnostik, zum Beispiel Lungun Emboli,
zum Beispiel Aortun Distection, Öze Fagitis, Unsovaita,
aber Akutes Corners, ein Bedotut,
alle Krankkaiten.
Ach, das ist alle Resulptöme, ja.
Ja, wir angene Pectorus, Corners, Krankkaiten, Unsovaita,
aber eine Oberbegriff, Akutes Corners.
Okay, gut. Ja, was mir aufgefallen ist,
ich bin jetzt also schon bei der Manöverkritik, ja, wie immer,
sprachlich ist einfacher, natürlich die Fragestellung
und ein bisschen komplizierter ist die Berichterstattung,
da offenbar sich dann so sprachliche Probleme leichter mal.
Was mir aufgefallen ist, dass sie relativ häufig
eine komische Satzstellung machen.
Ja, jetzt kann ich es wieder nicht, kann ich es wieder nicht,
nicht nachahmen, aber also die Geschichte,
dass das Verb an zweite Stelle kommt, das müssen wir irgendwie,
das war nicht so ganz korrekt, aber es gab eigentlich
nie Verständigungsprobleme.
Was mir aufgefallen ist, wo ich es mir kurz notiert habe,
der Familienanamese, der Vater ist mit dem Alter von 83,
das sagen wir im Alter von 83 verstorben, nicht mit dem Alter.
Und was sie da gemacht haben, das war so ein bisschen ohne
Überleitung, dass sie dann ja, wie so Stichworte gesagt haben,
ja Familienanamese, der Vater hat das und das.
Und eigentlich im Gespräch würde man das mit einem kleinen
Satz verbinden, ja, bei der Frage nach der Familienanamese
ergab sich, dass der Vater mit 83 Jahren eben an einer
Herzkrankheit verstorben ist oder so.
Dass sie so ein bisschen eine Überleitung haben, genau so,
wenn sie sagen Allergien, es besteht, da kann man ja
vielleicht sagen, es besteht eine bekannte oder es ist bekannt
eine Latex Allergie und eine Novalgien Allergie,
die Allergien äußern sich so und so.
Und ja, was mir aufgefallen ist, eigentlich hätte zwingend
dieser Begriff der retro-stellarischen Schmerzen kommen
müssen. Ich denke, das ist so ein markanter Begriff,
der das so gut beschreibt, diese Schmerzen und dieses Druckgefühl
hinter dem Brustbein. Und ich denke mal, das müsste man
eigentlich als Begriff in der Beschreibung mit erwähnen.
Also nicht nur dunfebrennende Schmerzen in der Brust,
sondern wirklich starke retro-trennale Schmerzen.
Mit Ausstrahlung in den Unterkiefer, das sind eigentlich
ja schon so klassische Symptome.
Was sie nicht so ausgeprägt wiedergegeben haben,
ist eben die Geschichte, wie es dazu gekommen ist,
dass er eilig etwas, was ich zur Arbeit wollte,
zu einem Termin wollte und abgehetzt war und die Treppe
halt hochlaufen und da mehr oder weniger zusammengebrochen.
Und dass er genau, oder dass er beim Treppe laufen
oder bei körperlichen Belastungen auch sonst
schon Probleme hatte, das kam für mich jetzt nicht
so deutlich raus. Ich wusste es natürlich,
insofern habe ich schon Ihre Angaben so verstanden,
aber ich glaube, das hätte man noch ein bisschen
expliziter formulieren können.
Ansonsten fand ich gut, zum Beispiel die
vegetative Anamnese und die Vorerkrankung haben
Sie schön vollständig erklärt und was natürlich
auch gut und richtig und wichtig war, dass Sie
unterbrochen haben, um zunächst mal die Vitalparameter
zu checken und das ist ja fast selbstverständlich.
Ja, aber bei der Acute Coronasendrom müssen wir sagen,
Interviration mit EKG, Vital Zeichen und
Bullet abnehmen.
Ja, also Troponier abnehmen, ne?
Ja, ja, ja.
Okay.
Ja, gut. Ja, ich denke mal, das sind so meine
Rückmeldungen für Sie.
Vielen Dank.
Wir hatten keine großen Verständungsprobleme,
würde ich sagen.
Sie haben mich verstanden, ich habe Sie verstanden.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie das ist, wenn der Patient
in Freiburg dialect spricht, dann wird es
ein bisschen schwierig.
Ja, und eine Note, Patientin hat eine Nectarie.
Ich denke, dass er eine Herzungsverdienste hat,
falsche Wörter in medizinischer Struktur.
Ich denke Diabetes mellitus, Hypertoni,
Prostatitis, Prostatitis.
Warum Herzungsverdienste?
Also er hat ja selber gesagt, er hat ein bisschen
Prostatatprobleme und er wusste nachts
zur Toilette.
Ja, deswegen die Nikri, diese Ursache,
wahrscheinlich, aber Herzungsverdienste,
keine, wir wissen nicht.
Ja, stimmt, genau.
Gut, also ich denke mal, aber Sie können
relativ entspannt am Dienstag hingehen und
noch ein bisschen, vielleicht noch so ein bisschen
sich überleitern, formulieren und aufschreiben,
dass Sie die nicht erst erfinden müssen
in der Situation, sondern dass Sie die
praktisch schon im Kopf haben.
Ja, also für die verschiedenen Themen.
Ja, dass Sie sagen, ja, eben familienalarmästisch
ergab sich oder die Frage nach,
sowieso wurde dahingehend verantwortet oder so,
dass Sie so nicht so diese Stichwort-Protokoll
machen, sondern dass Sie das eben in schöne
Sätze formulieren.
Das ist, glaube ich, hilfreich, wenn man sich das
noch einmal schriftlich macht vorher.
Und das checkt, wenn Sie mögen,
können Sie mir da auch Formulierung schicken.
Dr. Gönes hat meine E-Mail.
Dann könnte ich Ihnen das auch noch korrigieren
und zukommen lassen.
Aber ich denke mal, das können Sie auch selber checken,
ja, ob das gut oder nicht so flüssig ist.
Aber das wäre vielleicht noch so ein bisschen
für die Eleganz, ganz schön.
Okay, vielen Dank.